[Music]
welcome to session 44 in the worlds of
speculative fiction series in this
session we are going to be looking at
the short stories of cordwainer Smith
all bound together in this omnibus
volume the rediscovery of man and at his
single novel published under that name
of cordwainer Smith we'll see why that
matters in a bit called North's Trulia
and I want to take a little bit of time
to talk about what we're actually doing
here in the series so this began in 2016
as a in person face to face talk series
hosted by the Brookfield Public Library
and the general idea was that we would
meet each month and interested
participants would come I would give a
bit of a lecture and lead some
discussion about classic speculative
fiction authors so that includes fantasy
sci-fi horror alternate history
cyberpunk all sorts of other genres that
fit in there as well and it actually
took off quite well after an initial
session talking about the idea of world
building and how we distinguish fantasy
from science fiction and other genres
there were a lot of interests that
participants and we jumped in with
sessions on junior Tolkien and CS Lewis
and Eve and vote and and it just went
from there and we didn't meet every
single month there were a few where
there were things that a rose that that
got in the way but for the most part we
would generally get in 11
you know sometimes just 10 of them per
year and it continued on for five years
this is year five the only thing that
actually brought us to a halt was the co
vid 19 pandemic so the last session that
we we met was I believe in either
February or March of 2020 and we haven't
met sense that and and people have been
asking me here you're gonna start the
series again and I thought well the only
way that that's going to happen
like this online with me talking to the
camera and into my microphone and
sharing some of the things that I find
really great about these classic and
contemporary authors with you and then
engaging with the audience through
various means so as you're watching this
if you're one of the very first people
watching this you you are participating
in a premiere where I am on there
chatting live with you as you watch this
you can you know leave questions or
comments and I'll respond to them and
then after each of these online sessions
we're also going to have a video
conferencing session using zoom that
people have to sign up for in advance
and then they can talk with me in a more
unstructured manner not quite face to
face but virtually face to face in a
sort of sci-fi way using zoom and we're
gonna go over this stuff for maybe
another you know hour or 90 minutes I'm
gonna try to keep these videos which I'm
hoping to put out once a month in a new
series of worlds of speculative fiction
continuing this on in this virtual way
I'm gonna try to keep these to about 90
minutes so in all of the previous
sessions if you've been watching them
there's there's a few basic things that
we do I usually begin by talking about
the importance of the author and a few
little tidbits and sometimes about how I
came to read them and appreciate them
quite a few of the authors or are those
who I'd read previously and wanted to go
back to but a lot of the authors are
people who are suggested to me by
members of the the you know let's call
it reading group they're in brookfield
or by my online interlocutors who have
watched these videos and got in on votes
and wanted to make suggestions and so
I'll usually talk about what my general
impressions were and then we'll talk a
bit about the biography of the author in
the case of cordwainer Smith
aka well actually we should say aka
cordwainer Smith because his real name
is Paul Linna Barger and he actually
published under several other pseudonyms
we're going to talk a bit about his
biography and then one of the key
aspects of all of these worlds of
speculative fiction series talks is
narrative world's world building what
kind of universe does this person create
in their prose in the case of cordwainer
Smith in mostly in terms of short
stories all unified under this vast
rubric that we can call the
instrumentality of mankind and then we
launch into a number of philosophical
themes I don't know exactly how many I'm
going to discuss in this session I'm
going to just keep you know going until
we run out of time because I do want to
keep this at 90 minutes so that we can
have after that the the you know much
more intensive video discussion using
zoom so let me begin by by talking about
cordwainer Smith Paul Linda Barger one
thing that's that's kind of cool about
him biographically is when I went to
look him up at first it turns out that
he is a Milwaukee native so he was born
right here I'm not even sure exactly
what street he was born on it might not
be that far from where I'm shooting this
here in downtown Milwaukee right now
now saying that he did not remain a
Milwaukee resident as a matter of fact
you can call him kind of a citizen of
the world he he you know his mother had
him here so that they would have
American citizenship for him and then
very quickly young Paul was was was
doing all sorts of things all over the
place you know he spent time in
different boarding schools myself I
encountered cordwainer Smith the the
main author name that he wrote under
through encountering a stone
worried that that really gripped me when
I was I would say in middle school and
you know as I've said in many other of
these talks my great-uncle you bird
there were two things that were really
interesting about him that play a role
in in my own development as a reader one
was that although he really didn't have
much formal education he actually had to
drop out of school in elementary school
to begin working because he was one of
the oldest boys in his rather large and
poor family he was one of the best read
people that I knew and he really enjoyed
what we nowadays call speculative
fiction this broad swath that covers
fantasy you know utopian stuff horror
all the way over to hard science fiction
and the other thing well there's one
other aspect of that uncle you Burt
would not only read a lot himself he
took a great interest in everybody
else's reading and so he he really
promoted it the other thing was he had a
library in the basement of the the
prefab house that he and his wife my
aunt honey built after they retired and
they moved out of Chicago and they moved
to to Northwestern Indiana along with my
grandpa and grandma and and one other
uncle and aunt uncle Ernie and Aunt
Betty and the basement was relatively
unfinished but he put up all these
massive bookshelves and actually it must
not have been him who put it up it was
probably some of my uncle's who did
carpentry quite well because uncle
Hubert apparently was not a great
carpenter and he filled these
bookshelves with all sorts of stuff
sometimes they were were things you know
there'd be a place that he knew that was
closing and they were getting rid of
their books and he'd grabbed them all
and he had a lot of science fiction and
fantasy books well one of those science
fiction and fantasy books and I don't
even know which one it was
had a story in it by cordwainer Smith
and it's the same story that so many
other people when they talk about how
they first started reading cordwainer
Smith it's the same story it's the game
of rat and dragon which is this amazing
tale of how humankind is going out into
the Stars and encountering some you know
evil force that just wants to destroy
humans and a interesting alliance that
develops between human telepaths and
house cats ordinary cats that turn out
to be instrumental in saving humanity
out there in the stars and it was such a
brilliant story told so well for for
reasons that we're going to get into and
we get into the themes that I just sort
of fell in love with with cordwainer
Smith's writing and it's sort of stuck
in the back of my head and then when I
encountered some of his other stories
later on like The Ballad of lost Kemal
or scanners live in vain I didn't quite
make the connection you know but but I
recognized something that I really liked
about it and then later on down the line
when I was older I started reading
cordwainer Smith I think basically I
found a book in the library and it
wasn't this volume it was a smaller ones
there's several different volumes that
have gathered at least some of his
stories and I started reading my way
through it I was like well this is
brilliant stuff so when it came time for
series five year five of the worlds of
speculative fiction I wanted to make
sure to get this guy cordwainer Smith in
there he has been quite influential on
many other science fiction and fantasy
authors not least because of the quality
of his prose and the breadth of his
ideas you can see some interesting
commonalities between his
instrumentality of mankind and a few
other similar sort of developments in
other sci-fi authors that are thinking
about this long span of human history
and some some
similar themes I would say I am Banks
the culture series in a way is indebted
to that I would also say Gordon Dixon's
door sigh is is kind of going along the
same kind of lines as well in thinking
about the nature of humanity out there
in the Stars and how we how we remain
human and how we continue to develop but
that's one of the philosophical themes
that we're going to get into what else
is there to say about the importance
well I suppose one way to tell that
you've really made it as an author is
they create an award named after you and
there is indeed a cordwainer Smith award
out there so you can tell that within
the science fiction or broadly
speculative fiction community he's held
up to a high degree of respect I think
one of the the things that you can say
is everybody probably wishes that he had
written more than what we've got here
given what he had to say and indeed he
had planned to write more so that's a
fitting place to stop and and you know
leave that as a little tantalizing hook
for you
cordwainer Smith of course was not the
the author's real name his actual given
name was Paul Myron Anthony Lynn embargo
good German name right coming from from
this area where he he did have some
family roots and he did in fact write
not only under the pseudonym of
cordwainer Smith but several others
Anthony Bearden for his poetic works
he also wrote as Felix e forest and
Carmichael Smith he wrote novels under
those names but cordwainer Smith is the
the science fiction moniker that he went
under for all of these these really
interesting interconnected stories that
compose the instrumentality of mankind
series and he is indeed is that we
mentioned born here in Milwaukee his
parents did that deliberately
so that he would have American
citizenship his dad was a retired
federal judge from the Philippines who
got interested in the Chinese Revolution
and actually played an important role in
funding it so by you know two years
before Paul is is born this is going on
and his dad is over there and getting
heavily involved and interestingly
enough if you know your Chinese history
Sun yat-sen is a really important figure
right well that was I'm gonna just gonna
call him cordwainer Smith from this
point on I'm not gonna switch between
the two names that was cordwainer
Smith's Godfather so you know you can
tell that his father was was really
quite involved there and he got bounced
around quite a bit
he went to about 30 different schools at
different points and something actually
quite catastrophic happened to him early
on he was at a boarding school in Hawaii
and this is in 1919 he was born in 1913
so he was probably six years old at the
time and the stories are kind of vague
about exactly what happened but there
was some sort of accident and one I
wound up being completely destroyed and
the other I ended up getting a bad
infection so he was almost blind for
quite some time he never did of course
get the the other eye restored because
of the it was so damaged and he had to
wear a glass eye which he would
sometimes pop out later on in classes
when he wanted to surprise people and
I'll tell you why in just a moment so he
moved around quite a bit as his parents
also did as well they were involved in
all this stuff going on over in China
but but young cordwainer Smith or Paul
linen Barger was going from country to
country to country as well and he ends
up eventually going to George Washington
University and by 1932 and he's 23 years
old so this is actually you know he's
quite an achiever to do this he
graduates from john hopkins a place
where he's going to be
connected with later on with a PhD in
political science and you know again
he's quite active moving around all over
the place by 1937 he becomes a professor
at Duke University and that'll continue
on to about 1946 when world war ii
happens
he becomes a second lieutenant and works
in the Office of War Information and
this is where he you could say he
officially starts to become involved in
espionage and intelligence and and all
these other overlapping things as a
matter of fact Paul Linna Berger is
going to become one of one of the most
important people in what we later on
call psychological operations or psyops
he'll write a classic book about that in
1948 called psychological warfare which
is still in print and still read by
quite a few people and in 1943 he gets
sent over to China
in you know and the goal there is for
him to work with military intelligence
to help you know build things up and and
carry out operations now if you know
much about the Asian war going on you
know that's involving China Japan quite
a few other countries as well as World
War two kind of spirals out you know
that it doesn't really have that great
of an ending for the nationalist Chinese
but you know for the time being you know
Linda Barger is is involved with that
and in 1945 he's going to return from
China he takes a desk job he's still
also officially a professor at Duke
until 1946 and at that time he's going
to write one of his first stories within
this universe it's not one of his first
stories he'd written quite a bit before
that but the first story and the
instrumentality of man and that's you
know scanners live in vain and we'll
talk
a bit about that story in particular I
think in a few minutes because it is
worth singling out as a really important
story but he sends it out to all these
different places they all reject it
these sci-fi magazines as a matter of
fact one of the things that is really
funny about it that some of the
commentators have brought out is that it
was rejected as being quote too extreme
so you wonder you know you think about
the sci-fi at that time and you read
that that particular work well what's so
extreme about it right but that that's
that's what goes on and it doesn't
actually get published until 1950 we'll
talk about that in just a moment while
he's involved in the war in China he
rises to the rank of major and
eventually he's going to you know sort
of muster out and go into the reserves
he joins the Faculty of John Hopkins
School of Advanced International Studies
in Washington DC and they are he's an
East Asian specialist officially East
Asian Studies right but he's also
carrying out this sort of clandestine
psy ops training and teaching for CIA
agents at the same time and that's where
the story about like popping out his his
glass eye comes from one of the points
that he wanted to make two classes that
oftentimes would meet in his house sort
of under wraps was that you have to be
prepared for surprises and so like you
know you do that he pop it out say see
here's a here's a surprise for you right
now eventually he's going to rise to the
level of Colonel he does a lot of
military advising during the war he's
advising Chiang kai-shek who if you know
again your Chinese history the
nationalist leader eventually has to
move to Taiwan and is really the founder
of the early state there and he also
advises the British in Malaysia about
their insurgency operations that are
happen
and the United States in Korea he
doesn't get involved in Vietnam which is
kind of interesting he seems to have
thought that Vietnam was not a
particularly good place to be involved
in by comparison to say Korea or the
British in in Malaysia and he advised
John Kennedy on on some matters offered
those classes and psychological warfare
as we we mentioned and that book
psychological warfare comes out in 48 so
he's got a lot of things going on at the
time he's married to two women at
different times in nineteen thirty six
so you know he shortly before he becomes
a professor at Duke he gets married to
Margaret snow he has two daughters with
her the marriage doesn't survive and
they actually divorce in 1949 in 1950 he
gets married to Genevieve Collins and
would remain married to her the rest of
his life they are buried next to each
other she survived him by about you know
fifteen years or so he dies in 66 and
she dies in the 80s what else do we need
to say about him you know he dies of a
heart attack in Baltimore he spends a
good bit of his time you know traveling
different places and learning about
what's going on there and advising
people but Washington DC and Baltimore
that whole area really became his his
stomping grounds you could say which
makes sense for somebody who is closely
involved I suppose there's a few other
things to say about him biographically
so one of the things about the Korean
War that gets brought up in the stories
and I think this is this is a great
narrative about the kind of person that
he was there were a lot of Chinese
troops who were attempting to surrender
to Americans but one of the big
stumbling blocks to surrendering is this
this sense of losing face of having to
give in you know be be a loser and and
lose some of your identity by doing that
and so one of the things that that Linna
burger did that was really quite humane
was he came up with a way of a way of
talking in Chinese it's basically
stringing together a few words the words
for love the word for for virtue and the
word for humanity and said in the right
way they sound in in Mandarin Chinese
like a person is saying in English I
surrender like you know the word I love
right and so I don't know exactly what
the rest of it was but he had these
turned into leaflets and he had this
broadcast to across the Chinese lines so
when they were surrendering they could
in their view be saying I love virtue
and humanity and Americans could hear
them saying I surrender and everybody
could get along without killing anybody
any further in this really bloody and
and terrible war I think that's kind of
emblematic of who this guy was he was a
person of conflict of war of deception
of you know using psychological tricks
to beat your opponent but he also is
somebody who stood for saving lives for
love for Humanity and and both of these
sides fit together and there's so many
characters in his works where this is
also the same some of the lords and
ladies of the instrumentality some of
the other important characters another
thing that does fit into his work that I
think is important to talk a little bit
about so he was raised what we call a
high church Episcopalian
so Episcopalians our Protestant
Christians within the Anglican spectrum
or Anglican tradition right the Church
of England they became Episcopalian
after the American Revolution here and
they were usually an upper class in
America and they retained a lot of the
Roman Catholic ritual so much so that
Anglicans have often kind of positioned
themselves in between other Protestants
and kin
and to be high church means that there's
a lot of focus on ritual and and you
know sort of the communion thing as
opposed to more evangelical approach and
this shows up in his in his works not as
Christianity being you know sort of
thrown in your face or anything there
aren't even really a lot of allegories
like there are with se CS Lewis you even
though Lewis is quite inventive with
what he does with the allegories
particularly and for example the space
trilogy instead Christianity becomes the
old strong religion and there are people
who are transmitting it in the stories
and there are also like what we could
call virtuous pagans in the stories as
well who may encounter it and may not
Linda Barger himself also had an
interest in Coptic Christianity the
Christianity in Egypt and wrote some
some sketches for stories later on that
would have cops you know that I could
plan it that had Coptic Christians on it
and robots and and you know there's an
interesting thing going on there the
other thing that I'll mention too since
we're getting into his his stories now
is that the next really big story for
him was the game of rat and dragon and I
mentioned that that scanners was
rejected so in 1950 was published in a
book called a review called fantasy book
which was not a particularly highly
regarded series it didn't last very long
Frederik Pohl however had another piece
in there in the same issue that that
scanners live in vane was in and he
remembered it and got it republished
later on and then Linna Barger winds up
publishing as cordwainer Smith the game
of rat and dragon and then a whole bunch
of other ones and there's a nice like
little thing about this in this edition
with the story copyrights where it tells
us where each of these was published and
you could say that
Linna burgers publishing career is
really going from about
1955 to 1966 as cordwainer smith he
published other things before is these
other authors so if you look at some of
these really important ones for example
the lady who saved sailed the soul 1960
published in galaxy Queen of the
afternoon publishes gets published
posthumously in 1978 Gaiman Ratan dragon
published in 1956 in galaxies burning of
the brain October 1958 from Gus tables
planet that's a really funny one if you
haven't had a chance to read that you
definitely want to 1962 and it goes on
and there is there is actually one other
thing to say about this so Linda Barger
once he gets writing these these
cordwainer smith stories remember - he
doesn't have to make money as an author
he's already you know working as a
professor as kind of a trainer of spies
and psyops people he's published other
things he's publishing these things
because he wants to he had notebooks
there were there were actually several
notebooks
he had notebooks in which he had all
these ideas kind of spelled out for
himself he'd keep adding to it and
there's two different stories out there
about how he lost the first notebook
which then it's sort of like that
there's a story about a musician who had
been using a voice recorder to record
all these riffs and he had like five
years worth of riffs on there and the
voice he didn't back it up anywhere
always a bad idea and it like fell out
in the toilet or something like that and
the voice recorder got destroyed you
couldn't get the data off of it he was
like I lost all these riffs you know
well that that musician had to begin
from the start Linna Barger apparently
lost this notebook in which there were
all these other like ideas for stories
in that that universe that were spelled
out or at least sketched out
and then he said I'm just not going to
do any anymore of these and and so that
was that was it you know it was really
he was working on these things until the
end of his life though in one way or
another so this the two stories are one
is he's supposed to have left it at a
restaurant the other is it's supposed to
have fallen out of his pocket
while he was fishing on a lake who knows
whether any things are true but it turns
out that we know this from his daughter
he did have another notebook that had
other ideas so he didn't actually stop
and he continued now this is like where
the idea about the Coptic planet comes
from and she's got a website where she's
published you know quite a few things
about him and and other people's
recollections of him so that's enough
about his biography let's talk now about
the universe that he created one reason
why I call this the worlds of
speculative fiction series is because we
do indeed focus on the world-building
that goes into the series of stories or
novels or whatever it may be that the
author who were discussing sets out and
in this case obviously we're talking
about cordwainer Smith and the
instrumentality of mankind so there is a
massive narrative coherence in in these
stories that are being told largely in
this in this volume and they're set in
you know you could say a sequence that
spans millennia so they're they're all
after our time quite a bit after our
time actually and he's got some
interesting speculations about what's
going on the very early stories in the
narrative sequence not necessarily in
the order of being published do make
reference to some of the countries and
cultures that that we can identify with
for example the Chinese and the story
about how they they took Venus
when the people fell right or the the
war fought between Tibet and an America
in in the the little war story when war
has become this sort of like strategic
maneuvering thing that people do and
there's some discussion about how the
Americans criss-crossed
an entire continent with with highways
that you can still see at least at some
point in time but for the most part it's
all happening in a in a future for
Humanity in which the human race is
developing in in certain ways and that's
one of the key themes that we're going
to talk about and I guess you could say
that that's something that's absolutely
central to the the narrative universe
that cordwainer Smith is setting out is
humankind reaching out to the stars and
to space so there are a number of
planets that wind up being at least
mentioned in in the course of it not
many of them are actually explored at
any length but they're at least being
referenced or discussed you know great
example of this is the Douglas wiing
planets right which are said to or the
orbit their Sun or circle their Sun in a
single cluster and so being able to
chart out the geometry the the physics
of what's going on with them is supposed
to be particularly complex so there's
that going on there's obviously Old
Earth playing an important role there's
other earths that wind up getting called
Earth in some of the stories and then
there's a number of other worlds that
that are populated and quite a few of
these worlds will require considerable
adaptation by the human being just to be
able to live on them and we're going to
talk about the different kinds of people
in just a few minutes but those are
called hominids they don't look quite
like human beings anymore although
quite a few of the world's do in fact
try to stay as close to human shape as
they possibly can while adapting to the
difficult environment that they're
they're facing one of the planets that
plays a particularly important role and
is mentioned not just in this novel
itself North Julia but also in another
really great story called the mother kit
mother Linton's little kittens right and
it's this this place that has been
settled by North Australians and we
should talk about that world so they
actually they run across something that
changes their lifestyle but they decide
not to allow it to change their
lifestyle so they originally are sheep
farmers living on this kind of tough
planet right and the sheep are just
gigantic and there's this this fungus
that grows on them that's called strewn
and that is strewn winds up playing an
incredibly important role in the cosmos
because it's an immortality drug it
allows human lifetimes to be extended
far beyond what medical science was
capable of the time you know lives of
maybe 180 years to you know 200 years
almost indefinitely
you know let people could live to be a
thousand years and so this makes them
incredibly rich on their planet one of
the things that they do in order to
retain their culture and not lose who
they are is they Institute a set of
price controls so you know basic
foodstuffs and stuff things along those
lines tools very cheap any sort of
luxury incredibly expensive so much so
that some nurse trillions will go
offworld not just for our vacations
where they can enjoy these things but to
live permanently because that way they
can actually spend their incredible
wealth what we're as I'm nostril iya
they can spend it if they want to like
you can
by a you know extremely expensive
handkerchief that you know you can wipe
your face with but there's not much
point it so it discourages all of that
sort of stuff and that's where some of
the important characters in these these
stories including of course this guy you
know rod who plays such an important
role in in this the boy who bought the
planet Earth right well here's here's a
great sum up of this what's miss truly
alike someone wants things taunted up
like this Grail a the land gray grass
from Sky to Sky not near the weird ear
not a mountain lower high only hills and
grey grey watch the damn damn pool
dimpled twinkles blooming on the star
bar that is North's trillion all right
all the muddy Glover II has gone all the
poverty the waiting in the pain people
fought their way away their way away
from monstrous forms people fought for
hands and noses eyes and feet man and
woman they got it all back again back
they came from daylight nightmares
centuries when monstrous men sucking the
water around the pools dreamed of being
men again they found it men they were
again again far away from a horrid when
all right and there's also a nice line
here actually about mother as mother hid
ins little kittens wait for you down
there little pets they are little little
little pets cute little things they say
don't you believe it no man ever saw
them and walked away alive you won't
either that's the final - flash that's
the ultimate clobber cobber
and mother mother hit ins little kittens
are actually these genetically modified
minks who are you know used to
telepathically broadcast their murderous
rage out into space destroy essentially
possessing and taking over anybody who
wants to come to Knost rally a--with out
having proper permission and causing
them to fight and kill so that's one of
the interesting worlds there's another
world that's talked about
later on Xanadu which is framed a little
bit as if it's like nostril iya only it
has a different sort of devotion
obviously to pleasure right and in that
story the down to a sunless sea they
they talk about how's the Anna do was
created here we go one of the characters
says no under people here I think we're
the only planet in the instrumentality
that doesn't have under people except
for in Australia of course but the
reasons for an Australia and Xanadu are
at the opposite ends of the spectrum we
enjoy our senses none of that nonsense
about hard work building character like
the nurse trillions believe we don't
believe in austerity and all that
malarkey we just get more sensual
pleasure out of our unmodified animals
we have robots to do the dirty work so
there's there's some clear conception of
worlds as places where a certain ethnos
rains and you know if you've read other
science-fiction authors who do similar
world building you can say that there
are worlds you know where there's like a
deliberate choice to live a certain way
and that's that's the the mindset of it
doesn't just happen that way a great
example that would be Gordon Dixon's
Dorsey novels another one that comes to
mind for me is Orson Scott Card's novels
following Ender's Game when human beings
go out into space and there are
different planets that are devoted to
different things and even have their own
particular religious attitudes something
that that cordwainer Smith is going to
talk about quite a bit
there's also another planet called shale
and this is a planet that's originally
set up as sort of a punishment planet
but in some respects it doesn't wind up
really functioning like that in the same
way that that people imagined that it
would and this is in a story called the
planet called
what happens is those who are condemned
by the instrumentality wind up being
sent there and they are there
genetically modified so that things grow
out of them all sorts of organs and the
growth is of course incredibly painful
so they're given these really you know
hardcore drugs while they're doing it
they also have the possibility of these
these caps that they can put on that go
directly to their pleasure center as
well and so the people there live a kind
of screwed up existence they have that's
right super code Amin named after the
new French town where they developed it
the chemist hooked in one more hydrogen
molecule that gave it a real jolt if you
took it in your present shape you'd be
dead in three minutes but those three
minutes would seem like ten thousand
years of happiness on the inside of your
mind and so you know this is actually a
under person telling them about this a
bull under person so the interlocutor
says what's the use of it then
and so the ducat says well you can take
it after you've been exposed to the
drama ZOA outside this cabin you get all
the good effects and none of the bad and
the people who've been exposed to the
drama ZOA they grow all these these
things coming out of their bodies which
are then harvested so they're they're in
effect being turned into organ
generating creatures and they live out
their lives they're more or less
forgetting who they are and what they
are until the instrumentality actually
shuts that entire operation down what
else
there are three other planets that are
in the stories I mean the each of them
has names but it's good enough just to
name them by the particular names given
in the stories titles there is the gem
planet and the storm planet and sand
planet and what's what's tying all three
of these together is one character who
is
seeking revenge on the tyrant who's
occupying his world which which is the
last the sand planet and he goat you
know he meets the rulers of each of
these planets and interacts with them
and grows in the process it's it's one
of the few really continuous narrative
character elements that I would say
cordwainer Smith has in this millennia
spanning narrative that that he's
actually setting up where you have one
character who's in a number of stories
the other character who of course would
be similar to that would be the the
under person the Catwoman Kemal but he
is not playing exactly quite the same
role as this guy is and those three
stories are bundled together and sold as
a set in a book but of course you can
find them you know here in this set of
novels I don't think well there is one
other thing to say about Old Earth in
terms of the planet in in quite a few of
the stories there are these places in
Old Earth that are fairly unregulated or
you know at least there isn't this this
sort of like surveillance and overseeing
happening all the time and so one of
these places is called the gabite and
also has another place called the
berserk and very interestingly one of
the people who's living there describes
it as there are no rules but there are
understandings among those of us who who
live down here and this is actually a
good place to talk about some of the
other themes that that pervade this
narrative universe so there's really I
would say two main things that we need
to talk about we're going to look at
these as philosophical themes in just a
few minutes in a bit more detail so we
can talk about the planets people are
living in but the settings for a lot of
the stories are actually out in space
so space itself
is one of the settings and that means
that the ships that human beings are
living on and and in a traversing space
with those are part of the settings as
well so I think that's equally important
within all of these stories the other
thing that I think we do need to mention
is the structure of society and this
notion of the instrumentality and the
different people who live there so the
instrumentality of humankind are people
who actually do have the power to
intervene they they they engage in some
sort of like governing but not really
governing there's all these local powers
and institutions but the instrumentality
it's not an empire it's not a republic
it's sort of a it's actually you know if
we want to think about it it's kind of
like a pres birth tree right if you
think about the reformed or Presbyterian
churches and the way that they organized
themselves there was a set of elders
presbytery right and they were self
selecting and self reproducing by
choosing new members to join in in this
case it's the lords and ladies of the
instrumentality they're all you know
sort of high talent individuals some of
whom have a long-standing family
connection with this and they they
engage in decision making and and ruling
and can engage in all sorts of major not
just world-changing but humanity
changing reasonings and decisions they
also carry out some of the exploration
as well so they're the ones who you
could say make of things what they are
and there are all humans and then
there's the you know I mentioned the
hominids out there in space who
sometimes come to Old Earth then there's
robots there's lots and lots and lots of
robot
and robots don't have the same rights as
human beings as a matter of fact there's
mention in some cases of like they can't
touch a human being without their
permission they can't handle a
homunculus right and then there are the
under people and the under people have
been created by human beings from
animals and they don't have the same
rights as human beings as a matter of
fact they're treated as if they are sort
of analogous to robots and all of these
people are living within this vast
system of stars and planets and space
routes that cordwainer smith is
presenting us with there are a number of
great philosophical themes that are
raised and sometimes even discussed in
cordwainer smith's novels very often the
discussion is happening in the mouths of
characters who are presenting stuff it's
sort of like what philip k dick or
Ursula K Le Guin will do instead of
exposition on the part of the narrator
you know the characters carry out these
these deliberations and discussions we
may not be able to get to all of them
because I really do want to keep us on
track as far as time in order to make
room afterwards for the video
conferencing discussion with those who
are interested in carrying out more more
you know conversation about this and I
don't I'm not going to present these
necessarily in order of importance but
more in a convenient order that allows
me to keep my my thoughts straight
because there is so much going on in
cordwainer Smith's mind it is a matter
of fact I'm going to use a metaphor from
some of his stories to talk about what
we have here in these novels as a way to
start so you know he's trying to imagine
as science fiction authors have to what
the technology
for you know robotics and artificial
intelligence and all these other
associated things will actually look
like and you know he's writing at a time
sort of like you know again i used
philip k dick as an example though dick
lived considerably longer than then
smith dead you know at the time that
smith was writing they they were
starting to exploit what could be done
with electronic circuits so you'll see
him talking about like relays and things
like that we don't talk in those terms
anymore because we're used to thinking
in terms of solid-state electronics and
who knows what things are gonna be like
in a hundred and fifty years from now so
Smith has robots and the robots in his
stories have some kind of programming
that's part of what makes them robots
and the the programming is very often
going to involve some samples of of
brains from animals so for example in
the story think blue count two there's a
mouse brain that's used for a particular
robot in a really interesting way but
there's also robots that have human
minds imprinted on them as well so in
the here we go in in the dead lady of
clown town the dead lady is in fact a
robot who has had a lady of the
instrumentalities mind imprinted on on
her there's several others as well three
to a given star three different things a
ship a robot and then sort of a device
each of which has a human personality
imprinted on it also there the bodies
have been taken along to be reimprinting
and so you know this is you know even
even the scanners live in vain okay
they're not actually
doing robotics with people they're
turning people effectively into cyborgs
there's this really interesting idea
about being able somehow to convey not
just information not just data but human
responses human personalities so I said
I was gonna use a metaphor that's kind
of a cordwainer Smith is doing with
these books with these stories we're
getting so much of the mentality there
are at least one side of it of this
incredible complex character Paul Linna
Barger aka cordwainer Smith through just
this amount of stuff so imagine you know
even more imprinted upon people so
that's a fitting place to start let's
jump into talking about the
instrumentality of humankind or mankind
if you want to say and what's going on
with that so there is a earlier
instrumentality that occurs in one of
the in the narrative earliest stories
the instrumentality by the way is just
sort of a shadowy thing being hinted at
in the first big story which is you know
scanners live in vain and even in a game
of rat and dragon as well but in these
stories
mark elf where the vole mocks are gonna
actually appear and you know emerging
from this this human Dark Age right
queen of the afternoon there is an
instrumentality that is like holding
back the true men from any further
development and so they want to be able
to beat them and you know bring bring
about a sort of let's call it a
Renaissance of humanity which means that
we then can go out to the stars that's
right so it was the the people that they
are
going to try to fight against our the
twins and he says they were Chinese
Ian's philosophers now they are the true
rulers of the earth and we so they
believe our merely their instrumentality
their police force their power is not
over the body of man but over the soul
that is almost a forgotten word here now
say mind and instead they call
themselves the perfect ones and have
sought to remake man in their own image
but their remote removed bloodless they
have recruited persons of all races but
man is not responded well only a handful
aspire to the kind of aesthetic
perfection the jinns have as their goal
so the jinns have resorted to the
knowledge of drugs and opiates to turn
true man into a tranquilized indifferent
people to make it easy to govern them to
control everything they do unfortunately
some of our descendants have joined them
so we have an instrumentality that's a
police force for this shadowy group of
once we're humans but now no longer are
but they're calling the shots and the
human beings rise up and effectively
revolt against them and take charge of
their own destiny and then we have this
entire you know succession of stories
scanners live in vain the lady who
sailed the soul think blue count to the
game of rat and drag and we're plaintiff
warming is becoming what's going on the
crime and the glory of Commander sidsall
and what's happening through all of this
is that the instrumentality is carrying
out its its work and doing so generation
after generation now they have a lot
more continuity possible of course
because they you know once the the drug
strewn is discovered they can live for a
very long time right the dead lady of
clown town I mentioned somebody asked
her are you a person or are you machine
and she says I'm a machine but I used to
be a person a lady in fact and one of
the instrumentality but my time came and
they said to me would you mind if we
made a machine print of your whole
personality it would be
very helpful for the information booth
so of course I said yes and they made
this copy and they shot my body out into
space with all the usual honours but
here I was and then she says so what do
you say am i me or aren't I and then you
know there's all of this discussion that
happens later on the reason why this
this omnibus is called the rediscovery
of man is in part because they managed
to get themselves and when I say
themselves I mean the human race managed
to get itself even with the
instrumentality into a kind of sterile
utopia a you know everything going along
quite well the best story I think for
summing that up is alpha R alpha
Boulevard kind of a funny name right
there so let me turn to that little
discussion comes after the little
kittens and there's a great introduction
to what what is happening and why it's
happening at that time and then we can
go back to some of it I'm going to read
this passage we were drunk with
happiness in those early years
everyone who was especially the young
people these are the first years of the
rediscovery of man when the
instrumentality dug deep into the
Treasury reconstructing the old cultures
the old languages and even the old
troubles the nightmare of perfection had
taken our forefathers to the edge of
suicide now under the leadership of the
Lord Jessa cost and Lady Alice more the
ancient civilizations were rising like
great land masses out of the sea of the
past and so you know why are they doing
that you know why are they reveling in
all of these things you know
government's money fear death well
because without those things life starts
to become sterile and humanity
effectively reaches
a dead end here's a great line about the
instrumentality that I'm going to read
to you just to give you a sense about
how they operated you have to understand
the pattern of the instrumentality to
see how it happened this is in the story
drunk boat the instrumentality was a
self-perpetuating body of men with
enormous powers in a strict code each
was a plenum of the low the middle and
the high justice plenum a fullness right
each could do anything he found
necessary or proper to maintain the
instrumentality and keep the peace
between the worlds but if you made a
mistake or committed a wrong ah then it
was suddenly different any Lord could
put another Lord to death in an
emergency but he was assured of death
and disgrace himself if he assumed this
responsibility the only difference
between ratification and repudiation
came in the fact that the Lord's who
killed in an emergency and were proved
wrong were marked down on a very
shameful list while those who killed
other Lords rightly as later examination
would prove were listed a very honorable
list but still killed with three Lords
the situation was different these three
Lords made an emergency's Court if they
acted together acted in good faith and
reported to the computers of the
instrumentality they were exempt from
punishment though not from blame or even
reduction to citizen status seven Lords
or all the Lords on a given planet at a
given moment were beyond any criticism
except that of the dignified reversal of
their actions should a later ruling
prove them wrong this was all the
business of the instrumentality the
instrumentality had the perpetual slogan
watch but do not govern stop war that do
not wage it protect but do not control
and first survive so this gives you a
sense of the the scope of their power
and and what they're doing and why
they're engaged in all of this this sort
of stuff under old earth gives us some
some additional stuff as well that I
think is is quite helpful
this is where the Lord Stowe Odenton who
is close to the end of his life is is
proposing that you know they need to
have this rediscovery of humankind the
Stowe Auden says our population is
dropping on most worlds including the
earth people have children but they
don't want them very much he goes on and
he says most people want happiness good
we've given them happiness dreary
useless centuries of happiness in which
all the unhappy were corrected or killed
or adjusted unbearable desolate
happiness without the sting of grief the
wine of rage the hot fumes of fear how
many of us have ever tasted the acid icy
taste of old resentment that's what
people really live for in the ancient
days when they pretended to be happy and
were actually alive with grief rage fury
hate malice and hope these people bred
like mad
they populated the Stars while they
dreamed of killing each other secretly
or openly their plays concern murder or
betrayal or illegal love now we have no
murder we cannot imagine any kind of
love which is illegal
can you imagine here is something I
mentioned the merkins with their highway
net who can fly anywhere without seeing
that net of enormous highways those
roads are ruined but they're still here
you can still see the abominable things
quite clearly from the moon don't think
about the roads think about the millions
of vehicles that ran on those roads the
people filled with greed and rage and
hate rushing past each other with their
engines on fire they say that 50,000 a
year were killed on the roads alone we
would call that a war what people they
must have been and so he goes on and on
and the others say oh you know things
are things are just fine
Stowe Odin says people really don't care
about their lives we need to restore
something to humanity and so you know
we've got the instrumentality as such
which is really interesting conception
you know they've got their code that
they're following and then we've got
this open question well what is it to be
human what is it to be fully human is it
something that can be if
effectively managed or is it something
that has to be allowed to kind of run
wild so that's one really important
philosophical theme this governance that
we see in the instrumentality and their
interest in making sure that humanity
remains humanity and doesn't become
something else that's a good segue into
talking about the case of the under
people another thing that is really
central for the stories of cordwainer
Smith who are the under people as I
mentioned before the under people there
was actually the unauthorized men which
were animals that remained animals but
were given a kind of humanity to them in
terms of intellect and also maybe in
terms of some of their desires and they
play a role in those very early things
but eventually the the under people are
developed and the under people are
animals that are changed in in in
significant ways so a cat will have a C
in front of his or her name or a dog
with a D or a turtle with a T right they
all wind up being taken as embryos and
turned into effectively hominids who
have all these capacities you know the
with the dogs you have a real sense of
loyalty there's a very important dog
figure named Joan who is you know sort
of a stand-in in some respects for Joan
of Arc but also for perhaps Martin
Luther King and others as well there's
of course Kemal the the cat I'm going to
talk about cats quite a bit in just a
few minutes and there's there's many
others who play a very important role as
well the under people don't have rights
as a matter of fact in some respects
they they live more vitally than the
human
beings do because their life could be
taken away from them at any point in
time they are treated as if they are
robots and yet they feel and think and
in some cases actually have more to
offer than humans do so let's take a
look at the ballot of lost Kemal because
there's some really interesting
discussion going on there both of Kemal
herself and also by the Lord Jessa cost
and as a matter of fact there's some
here's a great line that I a point I
wanted to point out going back to the
rediscovery of man ever since mankind
had gone through the rediscovery of man
bringing back government's money
newspapers national languages sickness
and occasional death there had been the
problem of the under people people who
were not human but merely humanely
shaped from the stock of earth animals
they could sing speak read write work
love and die but they were not covered
by human law which defined them simply
as homunculus and gave them a legal
status close to animals or robots real
people from offworld were always called
hominids those are the you know people
who have adapted to things and are but
are originally of human stock now it
goes on and it says most of the under
people did their jobs and accepted their
half-slave status without question some
became famous those Kamal's father CAMAC
intosh had been the first earth being to
manage a 50 meter broad jump under under
normal gravity
his daughter Kemal was a girly girl
earning her living by welcoming human
beings and hominids from the out worlds
and making them feel at home when they'd
reached earth now here's something that
that they observed that'sthat's really
quite interesting so before I get to
that though here there's another thing
that that's important human beings and
hominids had lived so long in an
affluent society they did not know what
it meant to be poor the Lords of the
instrumentality had decreed that under
people derived from animal stock should
live under the economics of the ancient
world they had to have their own kind of
money to pay for their rooms
food the possessions the education of
their children if they went bankrupt
they went to the poorhouse where they
were killed painlessly by means of gas
so it was evident that humanity having
settled all of its own basic problems
was not quite ready to let earth animals
no matter how they might be changed
assume a full equality with human beings
Kamel who works at the the spaceport
knows human beings better than many
human beings do
and she's also used as sort of a conduit
for this messianic under person Etta
Kelly who is able to speak directly to
to Jessica stone who also plays a role
in Australia as well one of the key
themes that's being developed is the
liberation of the under people in the
ballot of lost Kemal in Australia in the
sad lady of clown town and several other
of the stories now I mentioned this Lord
jessica's jessica's was one of the few
true men who believed in the rights of
the under people he did not think that
mankind would ever get around to
correcting ancient wrongs unless the
under people themselves had some of the
tools of power weapons conspiracy wealth
and above all organization with which to
challenge man he was not afraid of her
volts but he thirsted for justice with
an obsessive yearning which overrode all
other considerations when the Lords of
the instrumentality heard there was the
rumor of a conspiracy among the under
people they left it to the robot police
to ferret it out
jessica's did not he set up his own
police using under people themselves for
the purpose hoping to recruit enemies
who had realized that he was a friendly
enemy and who would in course of time
bring him in touch with the leaders of
the under people so this is a you know
very important thing running through it
this working for the acknowledgement the
rights
of a vast number of people who do in
fact serve humankind and are elevated
from their animal status to I would say
a human status by human beings but who
then are not treated as fully human by
them you know there are turtle people
who have incredibly long longevity and
are used on these ships to like you know
just stand there and wait for something
to happen there are dog people and bull
people and all sorts of other animal
people as well and you know this is this
is something that I think reflects the
the you know the humanity of cordwainer
Smith this this you know again we have
to remember that he is somebody who saw
struggle happening across the planet he
lived through and participated in World
War two the Korean War these these
insurgencies that were taking place he
saw people struggling for civil rights D
colonialization all of these things
any-any wove it into the fabric of this
incredible story
so I also did want to mention one other
thing there's there's some interesting
discussions out there about not just the
animals but cats and the role that they
play for a cordwainer Smith so I'm going
to do a little bit of a digression here
obviously we have the the Catwoman Kemal
in the ballot of lost Kemal who plays a
really important role and she also turns
up of course in Australia and a few
other ones alpha R alpha Boulevard right
where she saves one of the main
characters but there are some other
places where cats are brought up and I'm
going to get to the probably the most
important one in just a bit which will
also be a segue into talking about space
in down to a sunless sea
there is a gigantic cat named Griselda
who is the steed of the Lord of the
instrumentality who comes there and you
know is investigating things and
Griselda is a gigantic cat they've just
bread them super big and they can ride
them I'm gonna read you one passage
about her Griselda seemed to sense the
pleasure at her her long effortless
bounce suddenly the ride took out a new
proportion over the head the ornithopter
which had brought the space Lord to
Xanadu passed on its way back to the
spaceport at once Griselda left the
pride and left feudal II after the
ascending ornithopter as she attempted
to bad at it
Kemal was used to use was forced to use
both hands on the holding ring in order
to not fall off ignominiously she
continued to leap and bat hopelessly in
its direction until it disappeared from
sight then she sat down to lick herself
and inadvertently her passenger so I
mean what we've got there it's a
wonderful description of cat behavior on
the part of this cat that has been
turned into a steed and unfortunately
Griselda dies in in the story and
Kamala's is very upset by this because
he's come to feel a love for her in in
the process there's another really great
story the crime and glory of commander
suds all commander suds all makes a he's
exploring space and and what would have
happened in this is you know there are
genuine aliens who they encounter and
then there's all these human beings that
went out into space and then essentially
got lost track of and one of these races
becomes completely male and they they
find ways to reproduce and they they
become quite a dangerous race the
problem is that the planet that they're
on all the women eventually develop
cancer and any
any females who are born will do so and
they become a really dangerous set of
people
commander studs all jumps there and they
find him here we go a rock ousia right
now what he does to deal with this is he
commits a crime I'm gonna read this to
you so here we go rules rules for
ordinary times for ordinary places for
understandable dangers this was a
nightmare cooked up by the flesh of man
motivated by the brains of man already
as monitors are bringing him news of who
these people were these seeming maniacs
these men who'd never known women these
boys would grow into lust and battle who
had a family structure the normal brain
couldn't human brain couldn't accept
could not believe could not tolerate
their breaking into his ship and they're
gonna get back to earth so what does he
do here's the description sons all
created committed a crime it is the
pride of the instrumentality that the
instrumentality allows its officers to
commit crimes or mistakes or suicide the
instrumentality does the things for
mankind that a computer cannot do the
instrumentality leaves the human brain
the human choice in action the
instrumentality passes dark knowledge to
its staff things not usually understood
in the inhabited world things prohibited
to ordinary men and women because the
officers of the instrumentality the
captains and sub chiefs and the Chiefs
must know their jobs if they do not all
mankind might perish Suns all reached
into his arsenal he knew what he was
doing the larger moon of our cocea was
habitable he could see there were earth
plants already on it and earth insects
so what did he do he had strange
resources he had twins or quadruplets of
almost every earth animal the earth
animals were carried in tiny capsules no
larger than a medicine capsule and
consisted of the sperm and ovum of the
higher animals ready to be matched for
sowing ready to be imprinted he also had
small life bombs which could surround
any
of life with at least a chance of
survival he went to the bank and got
cats eight pairs 16 earth cats
felis domesticus the kind of cat that
you and I know the can of cat which is
bred sometimes for telepathic uses
sometimes to go along on ships and serve
as auxiliary weapons when the minds of
the pin lighters direct the cats to
fight off dangerous talk about that in
just a moment
he coded these cats he coated them with
messages just as monstrous as the
messages which made the men women of our
Akio Chia into monsters this is what he
coded do not breed true invent new
chemistry you will serve man become
civilized learn speech you will serve
man when man calls you will serve man go
back and come forth serve man these were
imprinted as he says on the actual
molecular structure of the animals then
sons all committed his offense against
the laws of mankind he had a chrono
Pathak device on board the ship a time
distorter to be used for the moment or
for a moment or a second or two to bring
the ship away from utter destruction
what he does is he sends the cat's back
two million years he flung the cat's
into the nameless moon of a Rokia era
Casilla then the cat's having been
evolved for those you know millions of
years they come their ships glitter to
the naked sky their little combat craft
attack the cats would not exist in a
moment before but who had two million
years in which to follow a destiny
printed into their brains printed down
their spinal cords attached into the
chemistry of their bodies and
personalities the cat's had turned into
people of a kind with speech
intelligence hope and a mission their
mission was to reach suds all to rescue
him to obey Him and to damage ro cocea
so that you know he's created this
entire race you know a little bit later
on he says the cats are still there
perhaps the instrumentality knows where
they are perhaps the instrumentality
does not it is against all
law to bring up a form of life superior
to men perhaps the cats are perhaps
someone knows whether the Koshien is one
and kill the cats and and the cat
science to their own or whether the cats
won
perhaps the cats are imprinted by a
strange mission by weird hopes of
serving men they don't recognize so this
is quite an interesting way of
understanding cats as well these hyper
evolved cats who again we're bred to
serve humankind and did so there is one
other very important story of course
that that discusses cats and that is the
one that I mentioned is the first one
that I read which was the inroad for so
many other people and that is the game
of rat and dragon and there we go in it
there is this incredibly great
discussion and very brief but so
poignant of this pin lighter no pin
lighters are people who are telepaths
and they fight against these beings that
exist out in space who would destroy
human beings if they could and we're
going to talk a bit more about that in a
bit then it's happened while human
beings are doing what's called plan o
forming which which is a way of like
bending space that allows them to do
faster than light travel and go between
the stars
so underhill the the character is you
know talking about all these different
things that are going on and then he
talks about the partners so there's a
lottery that's being carried out which
which person is gonna get paired with
what cat you might say Oh cat why well
here's the description usually the
partners didn't care much about the
human minds with which they were paired
for the journey the partners seemed to
take the attitude human minds are
complex and fouled up beyond belief
anyhow no partner ever questioned the
superiority of the human mind although
very few of the partners were much
impressed by their superiority
like people they were willing to fight
with them they were even willing to die
for them
but when a partner liked an individual
the way for example that captain Wow or
the lady may like underhood the liking
had nothing to do with intellect it was
a matter of temperament or a feel
Underhill knew perfectly well that
captain while regarded his Underhill's
brains as silly what captain wild' liked
was Underhill's friendly emotional
structure the cheerfulness and glint of
wicked amusement that shut through on
shot sir Underhill's unconscious thought
patterns and the gaiety with which
Underhill faced danger the words the
history books the idea is the science
Underhill could sense all of that in his
own mind reflected back from captain
Wow's mind as so much rubbish right and
so captain Wiles kind of this cool cat
who goes along and helps them fight
against the Dragons dragons for human
beings rats for for the cats I'm gonna
read you what the cats actually do man
and partner could do together what man
could not do alone man had the intellect
partners had the speed the partners rode
their tiny craft no larger than
footballs outside the spaceships they
plan to formed with the ships they rode
beside them and there's six pound craft
ready to attack picture these cute
little cats in their little tiny space
bubbles the tiny ships of the partners
were swift each carried a dozen pin
lights bombs no bigger than thimbles the
pin lighters through the partners
literally through by way of mine -
firing relays directly at the Dragons
what seemed to be dragons to the human
mind appeared to the form of gigantic
rats in the minds of the partners out in
the pitiless nothingness of space the
partners Minds responded to an instinct
as old as life the partners attacked
striking with a speed faster than man's
going from attack to attack until the
rats or themselves were destroyed almost
all the time it was the partners who won
so Underhill is a telepath and he in
this case is actually riding along with
the lady May here's how the lady May is
described the lady May was the most
thoughtful partner he'd ever met in
her the finally bred pedigree mind of a
Persian cat had reached one of its
highest peaks of development she was
more complex than any human woman but
the complexity was all one of emotions
memory hope and discriminated experience
experience sorted through without
benefit of words when he had first come
into contact with her mind he was
astonished at its clarity with her he
remembered her kitten he remembered
every mating experience she'd ever had
he saw an a half recognisable gallery
all the other pin lighters with whom
she'd been paired for the fight and he
saw himself radiant cheerful and
desirable he even caught the edge of a
longing a very flattering and yearning
thought what a pity he is not a cat and
there's you know during the the story
they both end up being injured he winds
up being in the hospital at Caledonia
and you know the doctors is you know
saying things to him and the doctor says
what kind of cat did you have out in
front of you
Underhill then says don't call our
partners cats the right thing to call
them as partners they fight for us in a
team you ought to know we call them
partners not cats how is mine
this is well I'll find out for you and
then he says I can sleep I just want to
know about the lady Mae and the nurse
joined in she was a little antagonistic
don't you want to know about the other
people the passengers says they're okay
I knew that before I came in here and
then he says he stretched his arms
inside and grinned at them he can see
they were relaxing and beginning to
treat him as a person instead of a
patient I'm all right he said I'll just
let me know when I can go see my partner
and the nurse actually turns around and
says upin Leiter's you and your damn
cats right and it ends with this she is
a cat he thought that's all she has a
cat but that was not how his mind soar
quick beyond all dreams of speed sharp
clever unbelievably graceful beautiful
wordless and undemanding so there's this
really I mean quite startling discussion
of cat nature you could say and and its
possibilities and you know you can say
that that cordwainer Smith's books are
trying to understand the human condition
and its possibilities but he's doing
that also with animals and perhaps no
more with cats more than any other
species and then we could speculate
about that my time is getting short so I
want to talk about at least one other
big philosophical theme before we cut to
an end and I would say that is the going
out into space space itself in so many
sci-fi series is treated as something
essentially neutral you move around in
space you you fly around in it you go
from planet to planet star to star there
may be interesting anomalies in space
but there's there's nothing about space
itself that is going to be difficult
other than the time that it takes to
traverse it and the loneliness of being
out there scanners live in vain why the
scanners have to be cut why do they have
to undergo the procedure that they've
undergone well it's because of the pain
of space so yeah here we go
she's he's being krantz twitch means
that he's actually being given the cran
chewing wire that allows them to have
sensations again and he says all except
for the sudden red stinking roar of
coming back to his senses coming back
across the wild threshold of pain the
scanners have been turned effectively
into here we go he tried to remember the
days before he'd gone into the ha Berman
device before he'd been cut apart for
the up and out he'd always been subject
to the rush of his emotions from his
mind to his body his body back to his
mind confounding him so he couldn't scan
but he hadn't been a scanner then and so
scanners live in vain is actually about
these men who have undergone this
procedure to allow them to be able to
take other people out into space
and space is something that is hard
something that hurts something that one
has to deal with in that way then
eventually they find another way to do
things and in scanners live in Maine
there's a struggle between the scanners
who want to kill the person who's come
up with this knowledge and the people
who want to save them the next way of
moving through space is through these
gigantic sails that capture radiation
and allow ships to go a great great
distance but it's still slower than
Lightspeed so human beings have to be
able to to be at sleep for a long ways
and the you know each voyage takes them
an incredibly long time then we have
plateau forming and plateau forming is
where the game of rat and dragon comes
in why do they have to do this this you
know pin lighting well let me read you
what's going on dragons that's what
people call them to ordinary people
there was nothing nothing except the
shiver of planta forming and the hammer
blow of sudden death or the dark [ __ ]
note of lunacy descending into their
minds in a fraction of a second between
the telepaths awareness of a hostile
something out of the black hollow
nothingness of space and the impact of a
ferocious ruinous psychic blow against
all living things within the shift the
telepaths had sense entities something
like the Dragons of ancient human lore
beasts more clever than beasts demons
more tangible than demons hungry
vortices of aliveness and hate
compounded by unknown means out of it
the thin tenuous matter between the
stars so there's things between the
stars and the dark spaces in space
that will attack human beings plan of
forming and the Pin lighting makes it
possible for human beings to travel
faster than light but they also have to
deal with these complications the other
thing that's being talked about is space
3 and that just shows up in several
different stories and this allows like
an instantaneous transfer from one place
to another but it requires human passion
to make it work so that's a fitting
place to end all of these
probably all too incomplete and
tantalizing discussions about cordwainer
Smith and his amazing stories I highly
recommend that you read him that you set
aside the time and space to be able to
really concentrate on these you will be
well rewarded
[Music]
you